So to speed up virtual to physical
translation, the processor includes
a structure called the translation
look-aside buffer or TLB.
The TLB is a cache for translations.
So now you would ask yourself, well,
how is the TLB better than
just using the cache itself?
Well, first,
the cache is relatively big.
It could store a lot of translations,
if we only held translations there,
but we don't.
Most of the stuff is
in the cache is data.
One translation in the cache
covers a whole page worth of data.
So, the TLB that caches only
translations can be extremely small,
which means extremely fast.
Let's look, for example, at the program
that accesses 16 kilobytes of data.
For that to work well we need
about 16 kilobytes of cache.
But this is only four pages if
we have a four kilobyte page.
So the TLB that corresponds to that only
needs four entries to cover
the same amount of memory.
And with only four entries we can make
the TLB extremely, extremely fast,
much less than a cycle for
each translation.
Next we have seen that in a multi level
page table we access our cache for
each level of the page table because
we need to look up all those
entries in order to find
the final translation.
In contrast, the TLB only
stores the final translation.
Even if you have a four
level page table,
eventually we find what a given
page number maps to and
we just store the frame number in the
TLB, not the intermediate page stable
entries that we have been using to
finally come up with a translation.
So in our cache we will
have a 4-level page table,
4 accesses to do the translation.
In the TLB, we do this in 1 access.
So now a load or a store just
needs to form the address, access
the TLB to find the translation, and
then access the cache to get the data.
If we have both the TLB hit and the
cache hit, this can be done in one or
two cycles.
But what if we have a TLB miss?
What if we do not find
a translation in the TLB?
In that case we need to perform
the translation using the page table,
or page tables if we have
a multiple level page table.
And then put that
translation in our TLB so
that it can be used later when
we access the same page again.